a new study by Nielsen shows that
tweeting and watching television
actually does correlate to ratings which
I'm going to refer to this for now on as
the sharknado principle so this is you
know the Nielsen ratings in my opinion
basically have just been this made-up
thing that we've all sort of accepted
and that's not really just my opinion a
lot of people have written about that
it's just this made-up thing and there's
a box on somebody's TV somewhere in 1960
and we're still paying attention to it I
think this is really cool and I think
this is sort of the future of media and
the type of stuff we're doing around
here this social experience that we're
all having while watching TV and
something like sharknado i think is the
perfect example of this nobody heard of
it until about two hours before it was
on sci-fi network suddenly it somehow
got some traction on twitter and then i
spent two hours not only watching it but
having this experience on twitter
playing along with everyone joking about
how horrific and stupid it was um and
and it was kind of great and it gets the
buzz going so you're you're doing a new
show take part where you guys are doing
a lot of your tweeting the entire time
basically in very enduring camila during
commercial breaks and you're tweeting on
air I di by last week and you're
tweeting while we were talking how
important is the the social media
component to television and all the
other forms of me I think that you know
I think that we're seeing kind of an
evolution in TV viewing especially in
young people i think that people are
still watching cable news or cable
television i think that there is still
some amount of appointment television
but for the most part people are DVR
things and a lot of people have moved
off to the cable pay model and they've
moved on to kind of a hulu netflix model
and i think that this kind of community
engagement is a way that the cable
companies can really tap in to their
dying fanbase and bring them back
because if the entire globe or i should
say all of America at least is coming
together to watch it you know a program
live and it's more compelling it's more
fun if they're there right when it airs
because they can all communicate like we
saw with sharknado I think that more
people are going to tune in in that way
I also see I don't want to say a
downside of that specifically but if you
watch
live last night we all the pivot that
yeah right watch last week or maybe yes
yeah um I'm not sure if it was last
night the night be I think was the night
before a Monday night we part of the
decoder segment I talked a lot about a
shark week and about discovery and how
they opened up shark week with a
documentary about C Megalodon kind of
claiming that that it's probably still
alive it hasn't yet gone extinct and and
you know I obviously had a rich is this
huge crazy shark ray it's a big shark
that was extinct between 1.5 and 2
million years ago so I I have a real
problem with it's very similar to what
they did on animal planet and again this
is discovery communications it's all the
same conglomerate animal planet air to
documentary a while back about mermaids
and how they're still alive and people
thought it and people thought it was
real and a lot of people thought that
this C Megalodon documentary was real
and they've kind of defended their
stance saying that they want to feed
into the fantasy and blah blah blah
there was like one very short disclaimer
and to me this does a huge disservice to
science communication in this country
and I think I spent all this time being
very high and mighty and kind of blaming
discovery and blaming discovery and I
didn't take a moment to look at the
ratings and who's watching and think
maybe we should be kind of taking some
of the blame upon ourselves like we want
I say we I don't I didn't you know but
but many people want this kind of
programming and a lot of times even with
this link to Twitter these companies
these media companies are feeding in to
what the people are asking for anyway
now I think that's a horrible horrible
mistake if you are delivering news or
nonfiction programming but across the
board when it comes to fiction
programming I think what we're seeing is
the like idiocracy just like my judge
movie of America it's really dangerous
such a good movie yeah as long as it in
a you know rear sharknado during Shark
Week in trying to it's literally almost
the same thing it's that bad yeah I'm
sharknado is already getting a sequel
but what isn't there something cool
about that experience in and of itself
even if it doesn't really translate
those two ratings cuz i don't know that
the ratings actually a sharknado with
that research well you're they were not
as representing as the Terry twitter
right
Twitter it was nuts it was like they
were still beating out I think like
primetime shows on major networks which
you would never expect to happen on sci
fi right so it helps but it but that
experience that's the part that I think
is really cool like whether it's amazing
yeah it's like the same power that can
like liberate you know authoritarian
governments you know the Middle East
like a network you know ten years ago
the best they could hope for is like
some press and water cooler conversation
but today the water cooler is global and
it's on Twitter you know isn't it it's
an amazing world we live in our whole
like shared collective experience of
something is like changed yeah so that
means it does it even matter if people
are watching because that's the part
that I think is interesting here Nielsen
seems to be sort of made up and maybe
we're gonna get to a point where it
doesn't even matter what people it's
just what they're talking about not what
their lot watch it we'll see I was I was
like seeing all of the chatter I was in
Vegas for a conference of seeing all the
chat created I was tweeting like I'm so
bummed that I'm not working on sharknado
I can't believe what everybody sayin
just happened to ions earring and holla
you know so am but I still haven't seen
it that's funny we're here in California
so we I was you know it's all happening
during the East Coast feed so I was
actually just tweeting the tweeting of
sharknado I wasn't even tweeting sorry
there's not a simultaneous putting it on
a lot of these network so final thought
on this when you go to the old school
programming like CNN is now bringing
back crossfire which we've talked about
which i think is the absolute worst TV
show in a history of television and I
just saw that they launched their
twitter account you know got a couple
hundred followers is there something
about like the old-school media
companies and their sort of inability to
really handle the social media stuff the
way that a younger thing like take part
of what we do here can really do it
because it's true it's not coming from
some like corporate yeah i mean i don't
think that twitter buzz is enough to to
fund good content you know at the end of
the day and so i think that like people
still need to tune in and support the
shows that they that they like to watch
because it's sort of like the conan
o'brien effect two it's like when conan
was having that whole thing with The
Tonight Show and he had like obviously a
way bigger support base and then Jay
Leno but his support base they're not
watching TV you know so like I think he
was that's why that's part of the reason
why
relegated so I don't know I mean I think
that right now you know content will get
made and twitter buzz is sort of enough
to support that but yeah the ad model is
going to need to sort of catch up I do
think it's kind of a tough finding right
i mean it is opposed you need you need
good statistics to show what everybody
kind of already thought but yeah yeah
yeah the more people that are talking
about on twitter probably the more
people are watching there you go you
crazy youtubers twitter is good